how do you think Republicans can justify
blasting bionomics when what they're
saying about his policies is objectively
false people need to stop paying
attention to the polls and start paying
attention to what Joe Biden is actually
doing and the numbers don't lie
Republicans do
the numbers don't work what what is she
looking at what polls are they talking
about a new CBS Poll for one most
respondents describe in the economy as
uncertain along with calling it bad and
struggling only 34 percent approve of
Joe Biden the job he's doing on the
economy and when asked what comes to
mind when voters think of biodynamics
half of respondents said inflation smart
Americans 49 said higher taxes smart
Americans well only 32 percent said job
creation no comments joining me now
Senator J.D Vance Senator Vance well
look they are going to spend a lot of
time and a lot of money selling by
Dynamics my point on Friday night is a
point I'm going to State again for those
who missed it if Republicans get caught
and the culture wars and leave the
economic Lane to Biden
anything's possible do you not agree
that's exactly right Laura most
Americans are voting their pocketbook
and look Biden economics is a failure
and we need to Simply point that out and
make our case to the American people
that we can make their lives better I
mean look to the average Ohio and
bidenomics is higher food prices it's
higher gas prices it's the fact that if
your children can't afford a home these
days because interest rates are so high
and all of the homes are going to
Chinese investors and illegal aliens who
are coming in and taking them bidenomics
is the amiseration of the American
middle class it's the average American
family has 500 or fewer in the bank
account and is worried about taking a
vacation what binomics is doing is
taking American citizens and turning
them into permanent renters in their own
country people who can't afford a home
people who can't afford a slice of their
own nation that is not a record of
achievement but Republicans cannot
forget it and cannot ignore that reality
most Americans right now feel very
precarious in their economic lives they
have every right to and they have every
right to expect the government that puts
their interests first that's the
argument Republicans have to make and if
we do Laura I think we're going to win a
landslide 2024 and get a chance to
actually govern this country now uh
Trump is way ahead of everybody in the
field I mean it's just stunning I mean
at every demographic group he's leading
DeSantis went to New Hampshire today I
think to try to reset away from the
cultural issues he didn't listen to what
we were trying to say earlier but it was
set away from that and go back to the
economy
um I know you've endorsed president
Trump but at this point do you agree
that a discussion about like slavery and
a school curricula versus how much is
gas going to be in 2025. that's there's
no contest there what people want to
hear
yeah look Laura obviously the cultural
stuff matters the life issue matters
that's the American values matters and
you and I agree on that we also have to
recognize that most Americans are voting
their pocketbooks and rightfully so if
you think of the entire Trump campaign
he's still talking about issues that
most conventional Republicans are
terrified of including by the way his
competitors in the Republican primary
field he's talking about trade he's
talking about the fact that immigration
steals wages from working in Middle
Class Americans that if we have 10
million 15 million illegal aliens coming
in and taking homes from the average
American citizen then the next
Generation isn't going to be able to
afford to buy a home that is what people
care about and it is still honestly it's
an insult and a terrible verdict on the
Republican party that Donald Trump is
still one of the few people in our
movement who's still talking about these
issues they're arresting the movement
the rest of the party really has to
catch up here well speaking of this is
right near wheelhouse senator news came
out this afternoon Bloomberg reporting
that a political action committee with
close ties to billionaire Charles Koch
has raised now 78 million dollars in the
first half of 2023 with pretty much the
sole purpose of preventing president
Trump from becoming the Republican
nominee it's Americans for Prosperity
pack or something like that
um your reaction to that development
but we have to remember what that money
wants and what that money wants is two
things Laura it wants wide open borders
and it wants to continue to ship our
industrial base all of our good jobs and
our manufacturing to China and the rest
of East Asia they hate Donald Trump
because they hate the agenda and they
hate the fact that working-class
Americans are finally starting to fight
back we cannot ignore what's at stake in
this election this is the main reason
Laura I would say the folks should
support Donald Trump for president
because if Trump loses either the
primary or the general election all of
the old school establishment Republicans
will try to take us back to the losing
agenda that led to the commiseration the
end in many ways of the traditional
American middle class if Trump can win
and if he can pull out a governing
agenda over the next four years what we
have a chance to do is to reset the
Republican party it's not shocking the
Old Guard is putting hundreds of
millions of dollars against Donald Trump
the question is what do we do and we
have to fight for it yeah the
scientist's message is very similar to
trumps and if you listen to him in New
Hampshire today it was get rid of most
favorite Nation status for China and you
know there are a lot of good things
there but I mean I Trump is just
destroying the field right now
fascinating but Koch brothers or Charles
Koch is very worried Senator great to
see you hey Sean Hannity here hey click
here to subscribe to Fox News YouTube
page and catch our hottest interviews
and most compelling analysis you will
not get it anywhere else